[Music]
monsters
leviathans dragons and a very long list
of these bizarre creatures have been
created
in the game franchise of monster hunter
there are innumerable monsters to digest
and even sub species
and subclasses of them in the games but
here we are only going to focus on the
15
biggest and the most powerful of these
monsters to appear in all the games
and if you don't know by now then let me
tell you there is going to be a monster
hunter movie coming out next year
starring resident evil's mila jokovic
so anyway before that comes out let us
tickle your minds with the 15 biggest
monsters of this universe
number 15 the kuaru sepusu this monster
was introduced in the game
monster hunter frontier forward foe this
monster called kuara supersu
is a gigantic leviathan which is
classified as a frontier generation
it is 36.55 meters long or almost 120
feet
they have long brown bodies with smooth
gray underbellies
thick club-like tails and large
spear-like horns
they also have several large dust-like
teeth on the lower jaws
and most notably dozens of quartz like
crystals on their backs
heads and tails this kuara supersu
has the amazing ability to collect and
focus sunlight and electricity using the
crystals on its body
as a weapon number 14 the shen goren
on the 14th spot in this list the shen
gauran is a massive
carapacion or a crustacean-like monster
that have hard shells and exoskeletons
or crap-like bodies which mostly require
weapons with at least
green sharpness to break identifiable by
the grey skin
towering legs and gigantic gray yellow
balls of acid that they generate
and hurl from the rear of their bodies
the shen garan are so large that they
use
a low sean lung skull for protection
these colossal animals with their size
helps them to defeat most creatures
they stand at around 35.57 meters tall
or around 120 feet
number 13 the placejot this next monster
is a biscene riven
which are a class of monsters introduced
in the first generation
this class is evolved to be specialized
in swimming in just about anything
they are ambush predators adapted to
stalking prey from the water
and attacking by surprise blast yachts
can fire highly pressurized jets of
water at foes
and can use their massive size and wait
to crush the attackers
they are bipedal monsters with a woven
body but have wept feet
and paddle-like tail and are covered in
shiny fish-like scales
its gold crown large size is 38.77
meters
or 127 feet long
number 12 the yama tsukami this next
monster is the first of the elder
dragons in this list
and what are elder dragons well they are
creatures that defy typical
classifications and sit outside of the
standard ecosystem
regardless of any superficial
resemblance to a dragon
the yama tsukami is an unusual elder
dragon with an octopus-like body
it is covered in moss algae and other
plant life
and boasts a set of four thick tentacles
in addition it possesses two large
whiskers and an oddly human-like set of
teeth
and gums it produces some sort of gas
within its body
in order to keep itself afloat this
creature is 40 meters
wide or 131 feet number 11 the devilio
undoubtedly one of the most famous of
all the creatures from monster hunter
and it was introduced in monster hunter
3 de villo
is a very large bipedal brute ribbon
characterized by its uniform coloration
and muscular upper body its thick height
is littered
with short jagged spines that reach a
maximum height
along the back and the tail it has
narrow snouts
and a very large lower jaw covered in
multiple rows of teeth
spreading outwards from the mouth it has
massive powerful
hind legs but tiny arms that are rarely
utilized
much like a t-rex this creature attains
a maximum size of 40.97 meters
or 134.4 feet long
number 10 the fatalis this is another
elder dragon that is present on this
list
fatalis is a traditional black dragon
with a long
serpentine neck and tail along with a
pair of large
wings its body is covered in rigid black
scales
and lined with white spines its head
features four backward
facing horns and a row of enlarged
bottom teeth
fitalis is an extremely powerful monster
able to wipe out entire hunting parties
with relative ease
its primary means of defense is its
ability to breathe a stream of fire
and launching flaming projectiles which
explode upon
impact it is 41.1 meters or 134.8 feet
long
number nine the gog mazias this is yet
another ella dragon that was introduced
in monster hunter faux ultimate
it has a large heavy head with red eyes
and rows of sharp teeth
its wing our membranes can almost
completely retract when not in use
and its body is covered in thick
powerful scales carapaces
and spines of an indigo coloration the
most
unusual aspect of this monster is that a
sticky
tar-like substance which it uses to
incapacitate prey
and the presence of an ancient
dragonater lodged on its back
it is capable of firing a laser-like
beam of superheated oil
at attackers and also use its huge size
of around
49.2 meters or 161.4 feet in length
to battle opponents into submission
number 8 the najarala
on the number 8 spot we have the
najarala and this one is a snake riven
these monsters are known for their
serpentine features such as a long
coiling body and forked tongues they can
range dramatically in both size and
overall body structure
the najarala a snake riven has bright
green skin adorned with large
orange yellow plates on its back and
tail it has a long serpentine body with
small
though fully functional fore limbs and
hind limbs that aid it in moving around
on uneven ground the nigeria also has
large
big like mouth similar to that of a
parrot along with a pair of small
tusks it can borrow and ambush with
fangs of deadly venom
and this creature is 50.6 meters or 166
feet long
number 7 the cadious this monster is
another ally dragon
that was introduced in monster hunter 3.
kittious resembles a giant whale with a
face similar to that of a dunkleosteus
it has a prominent beard of fur and two
massive horns which constantly grow and
eventually overtake the creature's eyes
leaving it blind luminous organs line
the monster's underside as well as the
top of its mouth
which turn from blue to red when it is
enraged with its massive size of 58.37
meters
or 191.5 feet long it is strong enough
to cause rubble to fall from hitting
walls smash
open large walls and even cause
earthquakes by ramming its horns against
the walls
of the caverns it inhabits number six
the dire miralis
the giant miralis is a very large
semi-aquatic elder dragon
its body structure is reminiscent of
fatalis with a relatively short limbs
and long tail and neck
its body is filled with magma like
substance which pools
at the base of the tail the chest and at
each shoulder
each of these pools directs magma flow
to certain parts of the body
it can also shoot magma balls out of its
highly specialized wing plates
which fly into the air and land
explosively around the area
the dire mirales can also be fought both
on land and underwater
frequently changing between the two it
has useless wings but a very powerful
tale
the diamuralis is 62.88 meters long
or 206.3 feet
number five the lao shan long this is
essentially a hulking elder dragon with
copper red body
and cream colored underbelly it has
numerous dark
gray spikes on their necks backs and
tails it also has
comparatively small limbs with dark grey
hands and feet
and long tails on its heads are eight
large horns that curve backwards
and a smaller horn on the front that
points upwards and curves back
slightly the laoshan long's mouth have
small teeth
with several larger teeth on the outside
of their mouths
at around 69.6 meters or 228.3 feet long
it relies solely on its immense physical
bulk and strength
being strong enough to smash through
anything number four the gen [ __ ]
the gen [ __ ] is an extremely large
monster around 111.6 meters
or 366.1 feet long with a long almost
serpentine body shape
on each side of its head are sturdy
sharp ended tusk which can be broken by
hunters
and due to its back legs being vestigial
it moves either by dragging its enormous
body along with its arms on the ground
or by swimming in the sun a rocky spine
runs along its back where valuable
minerals can be found
the gen [ __ ] is at most times a very
calm creature
but will attack if threatened in
self-defense it ramps with its entire
body and throws large
stones off its back its size alone is
intimidating
never mind its abilities number three
the daryn [ __ ]
this elder dragon that was introduced in
monster hunter foe is the third largest
creature of this franchise
just a little bigger than a gen [ __ ] it
is a large whale-like dragon that is
covered in armor plating
unlike its relative gen [ __ ] its body
is jagged and sharp
with spine-like protrusions on the
forelegs and back
in addition darwin morons phase features
a single gigantic knife like horn
that extends several meters from its
head rather than the pair of horn-like
tusks
found on the gen [ __ ] this monster is
114.46 meters
or 375.5 feet long
number two the dalai mudder on the
second spot comes a creature that is
four times the length of a darden [ __ ]
or a genmoron
the serpentine elder dragon introduced
in monster hunter foe
is 440.4 meters or 1 44.8 feet long
which is truly titanic in size its
appearance is similar to the najarala
in terms of body type it has a snake
like face with bright red eyes
numerous fangs and many hook like spikes
along its body
which start out clustered around its
head and neck and becoming more spread
out along its long body
it is capable of using fire attack and
can shoot bright blue balls of flame
at the hunters as well as shooting them
skyward to where they will fall like
meteors
similar to a dire mirales and number one
the laviente
the top spot goes to the la viente which
is an unclassified monster that appears
in monster hunter frontier
season 7.0 it is a giant orange brown
and green tusk serpent
this colossal monster has smooth white
underbelly
in contrast to its pattern scales and
webbed ridges that span across its back
it has fin-like wings and spines that
align along the sides of its body
it can borrow both underground and
underwater the laviente primarily
attacks by smashing its face
into the ground causing an array of
flying rocks not much information is
known about this creature but
a japanese website states it to be
longer than the della murder
at 450 meters or 1476 feet long
and so with that we come to the end of
the list of the 15 largest creatures and
monsters from the whole
monster hunter franchise so be sure to
hit that subscribe
button for more monster videos and do
give out a thumbs up
to support this channel